[Musik]
hallo mein Name ist Luca und meine
lieben Freunde ich darf euch heute recht
herzlich willkommen heißen zur zweiten
Episode von Skyblock mit Luca
stehe gerade schon ganz entspannt am
Abgrund auf meiner komischen halben
bruchsteinkonstruktion aus der Folge die
vorgestern hochgeladen wurde von mir und
zwar Part 1 allerdings ist heute schon
part 2 und meine lieben Freunde bevor
hier irgendetwas gemacht wird möchte ich
ganz kurz die Zeit mal nutzen um einfach
wirklich Danke zu sagen der Support bei
Folge 1 Skyblock mit Luca war krasser
als bei Folge 1 von Minecraft und Luca
Staffel 1 und das bedeutet mir sehr sehr
viel eine halbe Million Aufrufe nach
zwei Tagen auf einem ganz normalen
Minecraft Let's Play von mir ein ganz
normalen Idioten hier aus Köln in einer
Map die 10 Jahre alt ist das ist nicht
normal das ist wirklich nicht normal und
ich bin total dankbar dafür dass ihr das
so herzlich aufgenommen habt dieses
Projekt und ich hoffe Ihr seid auch bis
zum Ende mit dabei soll er bis Ende des
Jahres gehen ich habe auch wieder einige
Kommentare gesehen wo Leute geschrieben
haben hey du kannst jetzt die Challenge
als nächstes machen und das und das und
das und das ist total lieb dass ihr mir
da so viele Tipps gibt ich habe auch
einige screenshotet die werden auch im
Laufe der heutigen Episode von mir
eingeblendet wieder oben rechts
allerdings möchte ich mich hier gar
nicht unter Druck setzen
ich weiß es ist in der heutigen Zeit wo
alles nur schneller und besser und das
kann man in so einer effizienteren
Möglichkeit umsetzen ich weiß dass wir
in so einer Zeit leben wo alles so
ablaufen soll allerdings soll dieses
Projekt hier wirklich so ein Projekt
sein so wisst ihr das ist keine das hier
soll kein Projekt werden von wegen hey
du sitzt gerade im Bus auf dem Weg zur
Schule bist eh schon gestresst und
schaust du das jetzt hier gerade an das
hier soll no joken Projekt werden was
man sich anschaut wenn man gerade das
Essen von Mama warm gemacht hat Eltern
sind nicht zu Hause es regnet draußen
und ist irgendwie 18 Uhr man muss auch
Hausaufgaben machen und weiß okay komme
ich heute erstmal eine Folge von man
macht es an auf dem Handy liegt im Bett
schaut zum schläft dabei ein deswegen
mache ich hier auch nichts krasses jetzt
irgendwie mit ausrasten klar natürlich
wenn jetzt hier im Creeper explodieren
sollte oder so logisch kann ich mich da
nicht beherrschen aber im Grunde
genommen möchte ich hier wirklich so
eine kleine
chill-insel Episode Staffel Skyblock mit
Luca machen also ich möchte mich gar
nicht unter Druck setzen das ist erstmal
Feedback Nummer eins zu einem
Kommentaren außer aus der ersten Folge
die zweite Sache die ich mir
aufgeschnappt die ich auf jeden Fall
sagen möchte ist danke für eure
zahlreichen Tipps also nicht von wegen
ey du kannst jetzt die Challenge machen
sondern wirklich Tipps also Sachen die
ich in der ersten Folge schon falsch
gemacht habe die ich hätte besser machen
können zum Beispiel mit dem Eichen
Setzling ich setze jetzt mal direkt
einen Baum hier vorne hin und lass den
mal so ein bisschen wachsen während ich
jetzt hier gleich ein bisschen in der
timelapse noch mehr koppelsdorfer baue
der mir wurde geschrieben hey Luca
bitte Bau die Blätter nicht ab
ein Baum droppt mehr Äpfel Stöcker und
Setzling um neubäume zu pflanzen wenn
man diese Blätter einfach verschwinden
lässt also es ist super es ist für mich
weniger Arbeit und es heißt auch dass
ich mir Items rausbekomme deswegen werde
ich den Baum erstmal wachsen lassen ich
werde allerdings hier vorne die ganzen
bruchsteinstufen so ein bisschen abbauen
wisst ihr warum
wahrscheinlich ja weil ihr könnt euch
mit Minecraft aus und ich nicht so ganz
allerdings funktioniert das hier unten
in die Kommentare geschrieben und zwar
spawnen Monster also Creeper äh
Zombies Skelette Enderman etc spawnen
nicht wenn man diese Blöcke die ich hier
fälschlicherweise so gesetzt habe wenn
man diese Blöcke da drunter setzen würde
also eine Stufe tiefer ich zeig dir
jetzt mal ganz kurz und zwar so dann
können die da nicht drauf spawnen die
können nur spawnen wenn das auf der
ebenen Level höher ist deswegen ist es
mein Ziel für heute so ein bisschen um
euch das schon mal kurz zu zeigen oh
mein Gott ich bin schwer bei 4 Minuten
wie kann das sein ich habe auch noch die
ganze Zeit durchgequatschen noch keine
einzigen Katja gemacht gefühlt ich will
meinen Weg da zu der Insel so ein
bisschen bauen das ist eine Schnee Insel
also wir sehen dort einen ich weiß
Fichte glaube ich liebe Fichtenholz und
vielleicht ist auch eine Kiste daneben
das möchte ich nicht in dieser Folge
schaffen das klappt doch glaube ich
nicht weil es ist schon eine Menge aber
in der nächsten Folge werden wir auf
jeden Fall zu dieser Insel gehen ich
weiß nicht ob es sinnvoller dorthin zu
gehen da hätten wir halt direkt
[Musik]
Kakaobohnen das ist ein bisschen die
Dschungelinsel da vorne haben wir Pilze
wir müssen auch einen großen roten Pilz
noch bauen in den Challenge steht das
auch drin ich habe euch die Challenges
das hier ist so ein Lia an Baum ich habe
euch die Challenges diesmal auch
wirklich unten in die Beschreibung
gepackt bei Folge 1 hatte ich das noch
nicht geschafft das Ganze zu
verschriftlichen weil ich die letzten
Tage bei der Wok WM war auf ProSieben
wir haben es leider nicht aufs Podium
geschafft weil in unserem Team nur
Idioten waren also mich kennt ihr ja
Papa mit dabei und rewi also das ist vom
IQ wirklich so wie ein Baumstamm das ja
hat nicht so gut geklappt wir haben uns
auch eigentlich nur verletzt ich kann es
jetzt glaube ich in dem Video hier nicht
zeigen weil das Video sonst gesperrt
werden würde weil sie echt ekelhaft aus
wo ich überall blaue Flecken habe ey ich
habe anstellen blaue Flecken wo ich mir
dachte die können nicht blau werden naja
auf jeden Fall
hat dies deswegen nicht so ganz
geschafft die Challenges direkt in das
Video reinzuschreiben der Baum ist noch
nicht gewachsen deswegen sind sie
allerdings jetzt unten also wenn ihr die
Challenges sehen wollt das ist ja das
Ziel des Spiels dass wir bis Silvester
habe ich mir so grob vorgenommen weil
ich auch glaube ich nach jetzt sechs
Wochen sky Berliner Insel weiß nicht ob
ich dann noch so eine mega Lust habe bis
dahin möchte ich auf jeden Fall die
meisten der challenges fertig haben die
bereits gesagt ich will mich jetzt nicht
groß unter Druck setzen aber ich habe
Bock auf dieses Projekt und ich glaube
ich blende euch jetzt mal die allererste
timelaps ein
die allererste timelapse Minecraft
Skyblock mit Luca Staffel 1
let's go
[Musik]
wir haben Fortschritt erzielt und zwar
Koppel collector
das ist allerdings kein keine Challenge
also nur für euch zur Info ich habe eine
andere Animationen das passiert das habt
ihr in der letzten Folge gesehen
allerdings habe ich jetzt erstmal mehr
als ein Stack Bruchsteine abgebaut von
daher kommen erstmal zur ersten Sache
die ich heute machen möchte und zwar
einen Ofen ich werde ihn einfach mal
hier Nebensätzen direkt dann haben wir
hier so eine kleine Arbeitsecke denn im
Ofen können wir tatsächlich wenn wir
Holz haben das Holz zu
fackeln machen indem wir den Weg über
die Holzkohle gehen ich zeige euch mal
eben ganz kurz was ich meine ich nehme
die eichenbretter hier raus nutze die
als Brennmittel um hier oben mein
Eichenstamm reinzupacken das können wir
jetzt ein bisschen Fackeln lassen und
dann kommt der Holzkohle raus und
Holzkohle ist genauso normale Kohle denn
wir haben hier natürlich keine Höhlen
seht ihr schon ich weiß nicht ob da
hinten ist eine Höhle ist nicht ich
glaube das ist nur dieses komische sind
das anthrazit nee diese Diamanten die
darunter hängen aber eine Höhle haben
wir jetzt nicht so wirklich von daher
ja müssen wir ein bisschen auf Holzkohle
zurückgreifen können leider nicht in
Anschluss von Diamanten Gold Silber
Eisen keine Ahnung was da nicht sonst
alles gibt Redstone kommen und müssen
den Weg über diese Holzkohle gehen
allerdings können wir uns damit der
Holzkohle hier direkt zack vier Fackeln
machen eine davon nehme ich direkt in
die linke Hand dann haben wir immer so
ein bisschen Helligkeit obwohl
eigentlich brauchen wir das gar nicht ne
sie sind auf seiner kleinen Insel kommen
wir machen so ich setzt die Fackel
einfach mal direkt hier neben weil das
war auch der Grund warum ich mir Fackeln
gemacht habe Bäume natürlich schneller
wachsen wenn sie Licht bekommen wir
können die Nacht leider nicht
überspringen weil wir noch keine Wolle
haben dementsprechend uns noch kein Bett
craften können und wir von daher ist es
so wunderschön ne
wirklich dieses Spiel
ich weiß ihr seid das satt aber diese
Spiel ist das schönste Spiel der Welt
weil du alles so machen kannst wie du
möchtest
und schaut euch das mal an das ist das
normale Minecraft Texturen Pack
das einfach nur Shader drin
und das sieht so wunderschön aus hier
alles
ich bin ganz ehrlich
man fühlt sich aber auch ein bisschen
einsam
das ist alles was wir bisher haben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so
eine Spitzhacke ist kaputt gegangen
beide tatsächlich ich habe beide
komplett aufgebraucht das heißt ich muss
mir auch jetzt direkt eine neue machen
habe ja allerdings noch zwei Sticks drin
zack haben wir eine neue Spitzhacke ich
werde mir direkt allerdings auch noch
mal vielleicht doch besser nicht Holz
verschwenden ne ich dachte gerade dann
könnte ich mir noch einen Schwert machen
und eine Schaufel und eine Axt vor allem
in der Baum gleich fertig ist allerdings
würde ich das tatsächlich dann doch eher
erstmal hinten anstellen pack mal die
Fackeln auch hier rein mehr brauche ich
ja gerade nicht und das Holz hier auch
ich kann euch jetzt erstmal zeigen
sobald der Baum dann hier auch gewachsen
ist dann was so ein bisschen der Plan
ist für die heutige Episode die ja schon
fast wieder zu Ende ist wahrscheinlich
allerdings können wir auch gar nicht so
viel machen bzw so viel mehr machen wie
ich heute vorhabe ich möchte hier vorne
nämlich erstmal das bezieht jetzt nicht
auf den Baum sondern einfach nur da
drauf dass ich hier vorne
das alles ein bisschen schöner machen
möchte schon mal und den Weg auch nach
dort hinten hin heute schon anfangen
möchte möchte ich allerdings an
allererster Stelle diese erdblöcke hier
retten die benötigen wir nämlich wir
benötigen jeden einzelnen AdBlock den es
in Minecraft mit Luca Skyblock Edition
gibt oh Gott jetzt steht der natürlich
genau da vorne das passt jetzt natürlich
nicht so gut
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht wie ist denn das wenn ich
jetzt den abbaue und den wieder neu
hinsetze ist ja dann schneller ich weiß
es nicht naja auf jeden Fall zeige ich
euch mal ganz kurz was ich vor und zwar
wollte ich hier so Treppen hinmachen
jetzt kann ich das hier mal ganz kurz
hier eben wieder abbauen zack ich hüpfe
mal eben kurz hier hoch es ist alles ich
stehe die ganze Zeit unter Druck ne wenn
ich einmal runterfalle ist das Projekt
vorbei vielleicht nicht vorbei dann
brauche ich ja wieder aber dann habe ich
auf jeden Fall wichtiger Items verloren
deswegen bin ich echt vorsichtig zack
die noch daneben der Baum darf jetzt auf
jeden Fall nicht anfangen zu wachsen und
ich hier gerade am rumwerkeln bin und
zack auf jeden Fall ähm möchte ich hier
vorne Bruchstein Stufen so hinsetzen
damit ihr logischerweise auf meinem Weg
zur anderen Insel keine Monster spawnen
werde mir dafür jetzt auch erstmal noch
ein paar bruchsteinstufen machen müssen
ich glaube dass da 60 Stück auf jeden
Fall ausreichen sollten und die setzen
wir jetzt einfach so hin dass wir zu der
Insel da vorne uns einen Weg hin bauen
können die kennen mich ja eigentlich
könnte ich jetzt auch einen Weg bauen
der nur einen Block breit ist allerdings
möchte ich es halt ein bisschen schön
haben und Ästhetik verbunden mit
Funktionalität meine lieben Freunde ihr
kennt meine Worte ich möchte das
tatsächlich auch nutzen als kleine
Baumschule hier vorne lassen wir ein
zwei Platz und setzen hier noch einen
weiteren Bruchstein drauf sodass wir
hier als erdblöcke draufsetzen können
und dann wenn wir einen neuen witzigen
haben die sind dort platzieren können
ich nehme jetzt den hier ich will das
jetzt machen ich will das jetzt schön
ist so auch wenn jetzt ein bisschen
länger wächst oder keine Ahnung was
macht mir egal es soll einfach schön
werden so der Baum soll dort jetzt auf
jeden Fall wachsen und dann ist das hier
ein baumpfad zu anderen Insel da vorne
hin wächst hier ein Baum dann machen wir
fünf Blöcke Abstand dann machen wir da
wieder einen Baum kann man ganz gut
sehen ein zwei Blöcke für die Blätter
ein Abstand ein zwei und dann hier vorne
tatsächlich kommt dann wieder so ein
doppelter hin mit dem Erdblock drauf da
kommt dann wieder ein ähm
setz ihn drauf wenn wir dann tatsächlich
irgendwann mal bekommen haben und dann
ist das hier vorne so ein bisschen das
Geländer beziehungsweise soll das dann
so ein bisschen auch verschönert werden
mit Bruchstein Mauern Zäune können wir
uns ja leider nicht machen aus Steinen
es geht nicht das sagt der Name auch
irgendwie schon versteinen kann man uns
normal machen jedoch können wir uns
diese Mauern auch ganz schön hier
eigentlich drumherum setzen so dass wir
so ein bisschen gerettet sind weil immer
wenn ich hier am Rand so ein bisschen am
arbeiten bin hey ich sag's euch das ist
immer ziemlich heikel
naja ich möchte auf jeden Fall diese
beiden erdblöcke hier auch noch
mitnehmen die hier vorne am Rand stehen
von daher hier einmal einen Bock hin und
hier zack brauchen wir den hier eben ab
den haben wir und bauen wir den hier
auch eben ab den haben wir auch und den
letzten haben wir auch perfekt dann kann
ich mich jetzt hier vorne wieder hoch
bauen und diese Bruchstein plötzlich
alle wieder abbauen so dass wir dann das
Geländer fertig kriegen auf dieser Seite
hier auf jeden Fall schon mal da vorne
waren allerdings das sind halbe hier
oder nee das hier ist nur eine halber
die restlichen sind ja ganz glaube ich
hoffe ich ja okay das sind ganze ich
werde euch mal ganz kurz zeigen wie ich
das machen möchte und zwar setze ich
jetzt einfach so hier hin zack zack zack
nehmen ein paar Bruchsteinmauern
[Musik]
es ist so schön
es ist wirklich einfach nur schön
no joke ich liebe diese Spiel aber gut
nicht ablenken Luca wir müssen noch
einiges machen in der heutigen Episode
haben allerdings fast gar keine Zeit
mehr und das beruht alles auch so ein
bisschen leider auf dem Baum das Thema
langsam weg wächst und der braucht mir
halt ein bisschen zu lang das ist ein
bisschen blöd dass ich das jetzt
natürlich alles verbindet aber das
können was anderes noch mal schöner
machen ey die Fackeln sollen auf jeden
Fall so platziert werden dass hier eine
drauf kommt dann hier vorne wo es hier
runter geht kommen hier und hier vorne
kommt auch noch eine hin dann mache ich
jetzt noch mal einmal eben ein paar
Bruchsteinmauer und mehr dass ihr seht
wo die Reise hingeht zack zack zack zack
zack zack zack dann kommt hier noch eine
Fackel hin habe ich hier noch welche ja
zwei Stück habe ich noch hier kommt
einer drauf ist da und dann gehen die
Bruchsteinmauern hier weiter dann kommen
zwischen den Bäumen immer Fackeln da wo
ich Platz gelassen habe so dass die
Bäume hier genügend Licht haben um zu
wachsen
und das könnte jetzt auch mal machen
ging ja ganz ehrlich
also ich nehme mir seit 25 Minuten bin
ich hier eine Aufnahme nach oder Teil
nächste noch nicht gewachsen wieder hier
vorne vorhin erzählt noch hier
ja gut okay können wir halt nicht
weitermachen jetzt ich ihr kennt mich
ich will nicht cheaten von daher zeige
ich euch die letzte Sache die ich für
heute geplant habe weil wir jetzt mit
dem Holz erstmal nicht weitermachen
können und zwar waren das die
leuchtbären ihr seht den Kommentar hier
gerade schon eingeblendet das wurde mir
nämlich geschrieben und zwar weiß jetzt
nicht wo ich das genau machen kann ich
würde das mal ich habe ja auch echt
wenig Platz ne ist ja was ich mache das
ich mache das jetzt mal dazwischen ich
weiß nicht ob das jetzt so gut schön
aussehen wird aber ich mache das jetzt
einfach mal ähm weil wir ein bisschen
Platz brauchen also hier ist die Mitte
genau machen wir hier äh die
bruchsteinblöcke drauf Zack und ein
höher kann ich glaube ich auch noch
gehen
der war falsch zack ich zeige euch
gleich warum zack da oben einen ran da
einer hin denn diese leuchtbären können
wir tatsächlich jetzt einfach mal macht
die man hier innen ist er sogar direkt
in der Mitte können wir jetzt einfach
hier so anpflanzen
und das kann ich auch schön abbauen da
kann ich ja auch Mauern für benutzen
fällt mir gerade auf und daher crafte
ich mir mal hier wieder kurz sechs
Bruchsteinmauern und platziert das ganze
jetzt einfach so zack zack zack zack
dann sieht das vielleicht ein bisschen
schöner aus könnten sogar Laternen sein
man könnte jetzt auf der anderen Seite
auch noch mal hochziehen dafür reicht
mir allerdings nicht die
Bruchsteinmauern und ich glaube dass er
dann auch ein bisschen zu sehr aus wie
ein Tor ja das waren die beiden Ziele
für heute oder die drei Ziele einmal den
Weg so ein bisschen anfangen mit den
Bäumen hier vorne drauf dann die ganzen
Sachen die so ein bisschen abschirmen so
dass ich weiß okay wenn ich hierher
laufen die gegen laufe passiert nichts
und die leuchtbären anpflanzen die Sache
ist jetzt leider und das ist halt auch
so ein bisschen das Ding an Minecraft
mit Lukas Skyblock Edition dass wir
jetzt halt einfach wirklich gerade nur
abwarten können
und das werde ich nicht jetzt tun
sondern zu Beginn der nächsten Episode
dann seht ihr der nächste Episode direkt
zu Beginn der timelapse ich das einfach
so hier abwarten lasse ist die
leuchtbirnen gewachsen sind so dass wir
was zu essen haben benötigen wir zwar
gerade nicht weil wir können ja wieder
sprinten noch haben wir hier irgendwie
Monster die uns hier hungerkeulen
stehlen und in der nächsten Folge wird
dann hoffentlich auch zu Beginn an der
Baum da vorne wachsen vielleicht
passiert es auch jetzt noch während ich
mein Auto aufnehme ich bezweifle es
allerdings weil ich wirklich kein Glück
habe bisher in diesem Projekt Minecraft
Diamanten in jeder Ecke alles sei
irgendwie ein Spawner hier direkt um die
Tür das war wirklich Wahnsinn aber hier
ist gar nichts irgendwie bisher das
Spiel
verarscht mich ehrlich gesagt am
laufenden Band naja ich würde allerdings
an der Stelle die heutige Episode Skype
wo du jetzt auch beenden wir haben schon
wieder Überlänge die Parts sollten
eigentlich kürzer werden als bei
Minecraft Staffel 1 nicht nur so 10 bis
15 Minuten ich hoffe dennoch dass es
euch gefallen hat falls ihr weiterhin
Tipps und Tricks und Hinweise und live
Hacks hier für dieses Projekt habt
schreibt mir gerne unten in die
Kommentare bitte respektiert dass das
hier ein ruhiges Projekt werden soll das
ist ein chilliges Projekt werden soll
möchte jetzt nicht wissen hey damit
kannst du effektiv voll schnell koppeln
sondern jeder meine timeless ich finde
das schön so dass er nämlich eine gute
alte Zeit das gibt ein bisschen
Nostalgie Vibes und ich hoffe ihr seid
mit dabei und es ist wirklich nicht
normal dass die erste Folge Minecraft
mit Luca Skyblock Edition vorgestern
eine halbe Million Aufrufe gemacht hat
in so kurzer Zeit
das ist wirklich in der heutigen Welt wo
alles noch schneller Bam Bam Bam
das ist
irgendwie wir kommen fast schon wieder
die Tränen ne also danke euch für den
Support ich habe richtig Bock auf dieses
Projekt ich weiß nicht ob es übermorgen
weitergeht mit Folge 3 oder in drei
Tagen weil in dieser Woche jetzt auch
Bau Simulator 3 rauskommt das wird auch
die nächsten Tage kommen auf meinem
Kanal da freue ich mich übertrieben
drauf und das hat für mich erstmal ein
bisschen vorrangig unbedingt das neue
Simulator spielen will da kann man seit
Jahren kein neuer Teil und ihr wisst ja
wie ich dort Simulator geliebt habe
früher na gut hier ist nichts gewachsen
wir brauchen noch gar nicht mehr lange
warten wenn es euch gefallen hat lasst
gerne einen Daumen hoch unter diesem
Video hier da abonniert meinen Kanal und
klickt selbstverständlich auf die Glocke
denn dann bekommt ihr einfach eine
Benachrichtigung sobald ich ein neues
Video hochlade und ich ähm ja gibt's auf
wir sehen uns in der nächsten Folge
hoffentlich ist das angewachsen Ciao
haut rein ich war
[Musik]